you
yeah hello welcome i should actually
switch the camera hello welcome to our
monday night stream hope you all made it
and hope you um see that the webcam is a
little bit different hmm yeah it is
better i think i have gone a new webcam
so the picture should be a little bit
better okay anyway i'm going to play a
couple of five-minute games and seemed
to see what happens here played some
games earlier which were very weird so
we'll see what happens ok welcome to all
of you in the chat by the way I've got a
couple of regular viewers in and yeah do
I get a game give me a game game started
ok playing cute wfm cute ok so what do
you want to play here mr. cheese
explained ok I'm going to five does she
have some more info no ok so
yeah my rating is coming back and I'm
getting getting back to normal kind of
her rating levels so yeah I forgot to
copy the link to the show I made a click
of a button though so it is relatively
easy to click on the button and then
getting transported to the show
immediately usually I do both but I
forgot to put put the text and the
easiest is to just subscribe to the
ICC's youtube channel so you just go get
informed automatically Bishop g5 hmm
okay i'm pretty happy trading this okay
some interesting question how to play
this now i don't think i have to play i
don't think i have to play it in my
usual way with the with the Knights
coming over I think I can do this and
get the night over to see 5 i'll
sebastian in the chat says WM cute as a
strong player maybe he played her before
oh yeah she destroys me all the time so
what he's saying okay yeah I've never
played her before it's my statistics yes
oh okay I'm happy to take of course
let's space more traits
and of course I want to trade this as
well it's not easy though probably have
to just expel it for ya that's a good
normal move for this kind of situation
my night here is doing all that much
care not sure we had to put it
interesting questions now should why
take on b5 or not she does him I was
more afraid that she would keep the
tension a little bit longer okay okay
okay covering have six
yeah it's a little bit of an annoyance
here it really is i have night h5 but
this is a not ideal
mmm yeah she did a good job here
definitely ok I think I'm going to do
this I know Queen III but I don't think
that this does so much the Queen comin
here it's not a big deal I'm I'm more
interested in getting the rupes traded
I'm kind of tragic check yeah trying to
trick her into this position here a
little bit because I think it looks yeah
okay she share recognize that the piece
is not doing anything there so now I get
the rooks traded and this means that my
position should Jack hey unless I'm
overlooking something very concrete
without roofs can I space disadvantage
sir Wow why to h6 myspace disadvantage
is becoming less of an issue check okay
check this is a huge thing now for me am
I not just winning the house now and I
think I did a good patient defensive job
okay I can take you for ice the thing I
think I will it also keeps the night at
bay and you can t 1 C 3
it's many points oh yeah forgot about
that oops shape-changing I totally
forgot about that possibility it could
be dangerous time warning god damn it
I'm such a [ __ ]
I cannot calculate to see if I check
probably she's got to draw any way now
what an idiot I play from this rendition
amazing check yeah I mean I'm a total
idiot for allowing this check check
check check maybe maybe she beats me
with this nonsense yep yeah she does I'm
such a [ __ ] yeah why do I allow Queen
287 this is just totally totally awful
ah black resins their energy just you
just blunder the whole game bear with
all the pawns and just this and white
resins anyway okay come on started let's
go for a new game Eddie masala and I'm
going c4d for 93 93 and Eddie has to
suffer yeah I really hated yet to to
give away games where when the game is
already over and then you overlook some
stupid Queen 87 ok Eddie yes I lost two
female players over the board a couple
actually
a couple down so here probably some look
to see one yeah yeah lost I lost against
women over the border Thea two games I
remember two games maybe there's a third
game but currently I remember two games
yes
okay Eddie yeah not not great in my
position ID I have to admit that he
irritated me with a chat comment heavily
don't quite know what to make out of it
and anyway so let's do check the
position he has our currently not an
easy time with if I was if I maybe he
can go if either actually it's possible
kicking this back so
how old was the youngest I lost against
means the youngest female player I'm
sure 95 m I lost I lost the game when I
was roughly 18 19 years old I wasn't
that strong yet I lost them I lost
against a girl from Poland she was quite
a decent player I think 2,100 something
so I was the favor but maybe by 100 or
150 points it wasn't like a huge huge
difference and I lost a couple of years
ago when I already was on in the 2400
against him w I think she's a wim if i'm
not mistaken here from Germany um yeah I
think it was a good game by her it was
some yeah it was one of those situations
in a in a team match where we were
behind and I had to try to win which
ultimately led to defeat if I would have
just done nothing I probably would have
had a draw in that game but it was one
of those funny game team matches where
you look around and you don't see how
anybody should win a game and then you
decide ok the only one may be able to
winning game by yourself and then you
try and kill yourself ok I think here
I'm probably winning a porn because he
has a little bit of a problem between
the Queen and rook because Quincy 7 i'm
taking yeah i can also take b7 this is
probably the strongest stronger way of
doing it hey dashed out a couple of
moves a bit too quickly yeah but before
right before where do you go now
planning revenge no wonder challenge ok
so there was a win against Eddie um
let's play a new game um gain started
again ok again many many tasty points
hopefully
yeah and here we go h5 I actually do
believe that this is dangerous it's not
just some kind of wacky move that
shouldn't work I think it is genuinely
dangerous Jen genuinely genuinely
difficult what dangerous f4 is
surprising okay so he's opening up
everything here and gets this opened
interesting
um knight c6 maybe I don't want to put
the night on that square to be honest I
would have a take my structure gets
quite gets quite problematic okay I try
that it's a little bit strange 50 50
I've got 9 h 6 yeah and said I'm not
enthusiastic about this but I definitely
would have some chances or on the
kingside yellow came at least no big
problems
there are some questions that about
being able to see the chat and things
like that I'm not completely sure what
you guys are seeing so it's hard too
hard for me to comment on it so my
thread now is not to deform
let's see what is coming up with really
really difficult to say what objectively
is going on here I might be in very good
shape but it cuts could be completely
different okay 95 and he wants you get
this going one idea is to play you for
just to bust this open for my queen you
know no I'm doing that
now there's some advice in the and then
the chat about how to maybe set up okay
bishop age three will win they exchange
I don't know if I want though but I
probably I want 96 for something
irritating anyway and lots of 95
possibly this is also interesting for no
chief form
I could i also have Bishop takes you
three okay you probably sex the queen
with 95 is a problem 95 as a problem
okay I have to go into the attack here
threatening Bishop g2 now Bishop g2
Bishop g2 Queen g3 should win and King
takes rook edge was made so 95 doesn't
work just have to fire yeah not not use
time for slow moves
it's tough for me really tough check I
thought that wouldn't work but maybe I'm
overlooking things I Kings you 10 Kim Ji
Won Mary
okay I've worked 65 though and I could
look age to on 93 or whatever oh my
goodness um okay this was my original
intention isn't that winning I thought
that would be winning it doesn't have a
check I know check means over actually
you
white resigns yo is made on g 2 oroo
cage one it's a not not much left here I
have no idea what was happening before
but it was I think pretty
straightforward at least ok game next
game dynamo 63 going c4 I have six so g3
set Grandmaster Koosman right I like
psychos mania moon ok it's a good
theoretical player I wonder why is
reading is so low they're ok so I'm
going for the before plan here
so he's six okay okay just counter text
in the center okay I probably have to
take it's not something that I know yeah
my on the queenside is of course slow ok
take 16 I wonder if i just take or allow
him to take if I take you will get it
back anyway so and 2 g-3 is not always
the right move in the English but it's
something that can be played almost all
the time ok
hmm quite an unconventional position see
Paul might be strong
so what to do
c3 is a really annoying I don't want to
take on c4 as that tips gives Bishop f5
always later anyway I have to make a
decision svend Fisher asks do you know
Madrid unfortunately not never been to
Madrid it didn't work out i had some
plans when i was playing in the european
club cup in bilbao to maybe a maker
combine that also with the visit to the
capital of spain but it just didn't work
out couldn't couldn't get the time going
definitely on on my list I definitely
would like to visit both the Barcelona
enter Madrid whoa that's a good move of
course a I didn't see it coming Wow ok
cannot take the night because of bishops
III check no word was he's got Knight to
c4 oh I'm stupid him I'm stupid I was I
was just not seen night c4 was it's very
simple but i didn't i didn't quite see
that idea
Wow put a bad game yeah this lines but
see 4583 before would be one I don't
quite handle them well really don't i
just got context is three ok then i have
root chicks c4i please bloody shame
always hate to give away games totally
easily Alec with those simple tactics
and stuff there's a question what I
think of feeders pay-to-play suggestion
for the world championship cycle um I
think it is this it is this thing if you
can bring up the the prize fund that any
penny 2,700 player can play or something
like that I haven't looked at the
details it seems very a little bit yeah
what what you call it doesn't seem like
a very sports like way of putting it
yeah I cannot really see something
similar happening in other activities
what a rotten position
time warning you really have no nothing
yet at all yea high to low in the chit
not quite sure why this suggestion has
something Hillary Clinton like if it
comes to ya by things I think Donald
Trump is probably in the same boat
Kasparov doesn't need a loan I can tell
you that I mean but he doesn't want to
play a match against Magnus cars and
then get killed so this won't happen but
this is very interesting for for those
those countries who glutes got lots of
money yeah like I say by John or yeah
the Gulf states or something and maybe
all of a sudden we get tons of top
players yeah go to Qatar like they do
that in other sports at qatar bought a
whole team of handball us yet and this
is completely crazy and they regain turn
at least they gained a second place in
the world championships okay so um yeah
I'm kind of hanging on here but he
somehow didn't kill me yet but position
is very bad
yeah I don't think we should go into a
political discussion the ayah this
didn't really work out well in earlier
in earlier streams so I was just saying
I didn't really understand why you
picked something particularly Clinton
like about paying for something okay so
check the position is unfortunately so
bad that even bad technical play doesn't
save me check oops check check check
check black forfeits on time yeah hey
sorry if you take 50 moves to win this
position not my problem ah so let's do a
new game huh so let's get going I know
that it was a bit of a dirty time win
but I really didn't see the point I mean
he didn't kill me for for ages so let's
just continue he's so died in deep
independiente have a real problem with
this name I think I played him just just
last time I just want to get writing
going here Shack and see back to 2400
well what are we discussing here yeah
Xue Shan yep she switched Federation's
to cut out she married amor de mudar
hockey or something so some something
like that was his name or is his name
I'll moody okemo d aki something like
that I'm sorry about this not quite
yeah see you know probably hard to
France I think she is a chance to chess
coach and China now for a long time she
was extremely strong and I'm sure where
the 2700 2580 or something like that and
at a time when this meant yeah clearly
the number two spot behind poor girl
judit polgár of course yeah I've given
up a pawn I think this is a line where
black gets compensation hope I'm not
wrong
yes let's see how in deep in evening i
can't pronounce independence but
independiente i have got problems please
no take back some Quincy five or
something I have good compensation for
the pond don't you think therefore I can
also just take a two or something but
this is very meek more about f5 here ok
let's go ahead five and I'm not
interested in that porn I didn't see
that Bishop c4 is a check it's not a big
deal though I think check 95 does he
have some rookie born miracle move maybe
I can do this
hmm I was thinking I should be a tactic
here quite quite get it working ok let's
go could have six I wanted to go to d6
rationed anyway let's see
yeah okay I shouldn't have done that at
sacrificed probably i think the SEC was
actually good but 25 didn't lose
anything for me yes not for wine
back in the night I forgot I want to
kill 93 and then c6 yeah okay please
take it and end my mother is there I
wasn't there was a bad game whoa why
does he not just take the night okay
black resigns yeah sorry after this is
something that I have to check real
quickly because I must have very good
compensation for the pawn let's check
how to hard to believe that there
shouldn't be this the engine doesn't
doesn't find an advantage for black just
equal well yeah then it wasn't wasn't
all that grade and I should it seems
just play that pedestrian move and be
fine ma'am okay that's what you get
sometimes for being creative okay so new
game next game game started against say
do naam okay it's an i am from Turkey
yeah played a couple of times against
men I have a very clear recollection of
the games here step 2 clay very
dangerous
so what are you going to do mp6 so we
get some sort of double quadruple if you
ain't ghetto with black hands doing a
strange knight on c6
and only d6 night bd7 is the standard
way of playing this kind of thing
maybe I should have any way yeah I'm not
just sure my night only three years I
mean I'm threatening 95 but okay so it's
not reacting to my game I have any way I
thought you would do something about it
it's by the way it's not it's not
necessarily winning for me or anything
but it should be nice so takes and
Quincy to or yeah i mean i have to take
i can take on f6 as well of it that
doesn't do much so oh he will get in
yeah you will get in c 5 and this still
makes this quite a quite an ok position
yeah now is still ok
yes he's training everything here
can I take b6 here or what's the deal
hmm I'm a very bad score against this
player and basically every game I was
winning so this is a completely normal
way how the game goes but at the end i
will lose due to some whatever some real
tactical i cannot tell you so
yeah it's difficult to win this though
the likelihood of the queenside being
completely traded is very high and then
it's really very dry so what to do
yeah to take the ear porn
probably doing this far too difficult
you
yeah I know this is the moment where I
lose the game somehow yeah to to some
rookie tool or whatever
okay so mr. say do not okay I grew up
these six or something
is their tactic Queen d525 and rookie
one is the thing
I've made it difficult of course you
will never trade if I played the Queen
to g2 and it was suggested time morning
yeah this is busy it just isn't easy I
mean what can you do I've made it
difficult as you know and I did not see
this Fred move I'm hating this stuff I
really hate it why am I getting into
this trouble is always against this guy
I mean really every game ok check check
it's really unbelievable after the way
the game went it's probably managers in
managing this even check check game drum
man ma yes is just like hey it is just I
should never give him the C porn I mean
this is just technically terrible when
ok one
whatever I just absolutely never should
allow the sea porn to go up this is just
terrible well yeah you also had a
chairman okay let's go for a new game
well at least I played somewhat quickly
but them again cannot allow the c1 to
come to see three to see to whatever
this is not easy by the way gain started
Quincy 3 was forced it's not for us you
can go to d5 sorry you will never trade
queens so um solid opening combined with
a lending with Dutch now that's
impossible to say especially by in
particularly particular combined with
the learning Dutch is there some kind of
I don't think that there's a certain how
do you call it if you if you play the
learning were Dutch there's no natural
partner opening or anything like that
it's just a very very specific kind of
kind of opening so I wouldn't really
know what to recommend them no that's
not magnus carlsen system Ellen haga
sorta or something I'm not pronouncing
this correctly that much I know
yeah my English series will come out in
the next couple of days I can only say
that it's not on my desk really I have
did every I did everything c5 holy moly
Wow
just weakening d5 like crazy how many
living grandmasters are there worldwide
I think roughly 1,200 maybe 1,300
something like that
hmm funny 93 you should be several 91 in
Game one so a little bit better for wine
I mean in general if you look for a
solid opening against d for a lost art
openings the Queens gambit declined
always comes to mind okay so so so oh my
god she gets to support his in her night
with the rook
no there's a question if Knight c3 on
move towards more flexible in the
English opening and I cannot you cannot
really say that it's um it's just a
little bit different there's no quality
kind of there's no difference in quality
between the most just some differences
okay so i found very weird what she
played but she got a decent position out
of it I sorry I def for the whole time
some
make Partridge boy asked if I would ever
consider doing a repertoire based on the
Rubenstein variation against the news oh
why not I mean there's very little that
I wouldn't consider looking at as long
as this is so it is good stuff that that
that good stuff that you can recommend
okay night over to see three so here we
go I would like to go forward the snide
deform it's a little bit annoying I
should have played Bishop age three
actually to provoke this weakness okay I
can still do that oh my god what is she
doing here g5 this is the kind of move
that if you don't review that you feel
very bad looks like suicidal weakening
but looks good okay 90 form okay let's
do this why not so
I can get this over to g3 as well
tough it's tough it's very strange this
g5 stuff but doesn't seem to be all that
bad
I have no idea what's going on here
absolutely no oh my god let's scare me
oh my god no I'm really scared time
warning
I get the King away somewhere or
something this looks damn scary early
okay try him get this over I have no
time on the clock I didn't see that one
coming oh she's killing me she's totally
killing me here neither 3 i'm missing oh
my god and she says she sees everything
check absolutely everything
check check what ah there is no made the
rook is covering it check check check
check check check white for fence on
time just as hell Beca screen c3 what
she deserves that when that was a very
very very very strange game fair ever
see five is a shocking move ready and as
I should I should completely refuted but
i didn't manage this was good yeah i
mean i don't know it certainly should be
good for Wyatt but kind of stunt know
this game also here this is g 5 is crazy
move but you know i'm just playing like
a just can just take here and win this
porner i am yeah i just play badly and
here Wow
and all she played it very well I mean
the engine just says white wins white
wins wide wins but it was all very scary
stuff here with with through age six
cents and so on now I'm in bad shape bad
shape yeah the idea of course I'm losing
now she did a good job them very nicely
very nicely getting getting counterplay
the biggest mistake I should just take
after g5 this is game over actually this
this and this is collapsing and there's
no no counter play whatsoever yeah
anyway yeah it was a tough session it
didn't scroll that well at the end but
yeah I'm so reasonably okay with it it's
um still damn hot here in the office and
if I can get some wins it's okay okay um
I hope you enjoy enjoy the show and I'll
be back next Monday of course with the
new edition of this same time same
channel on the ICC youtube channel ok
guys thanks for watching bye bye